Rudy Giuliani says he doesn't know and
doesn't care when President Trump found
out about the 130 thousand dollar
payment to adult film star stormy
Daniels the president's lawyer said
yesterday he's focused on the law more
than the facts right now that's a quote
he also indicated that Daniels may not
have been the only woman to receive hush
money Paula Reid is at the White House
Paula good morning good morning Rudy
Giuliani has only been part of the
president's legal team for about two
weeks now but in that time he continues
to make headlines about that 2016 hush
money payment to Daniel's his comments
are raising new questions about just how
much the president knew about that
agreement I would think if it was
necessary yes Rudy Giuliani suggested
Sunday that Michael Cohen may have paid
hush money on behalf of President Trump
to other women in addition to adult film
star stormy Daniels he conducted
business for the president which means
he had legal fees monies laid out and
expenditures he says the president
reimbursed Cohen with his own money
through a monthly retainer agreement for
his services Michael Cohen takes care of
situations like this then gets paid for
the sometimes Giuliani's shocking claim
that the president knew about the hush
money deal directly contradicts the
president's statement to reporters last
month aboard Air Force One
[Music]
it is time for Rudy Guiliani to be put
out the pasture
Daniel's attorney Michael avenatti
blasted Giuliani's legal strategy as
storms a-comin baby and dismissed
questions about whether his clients
appearance on Saturday Night Live
undermines the credibility of her case
we've proven to be very serious about
this case
Giuliani also insisted Saturday on Fox
that the payment was not a campaign
contribution and was instead an
expenditure even if it was for campaign
purposes if it was to save his family to
save embarrassment it's not a campaign
donation campaign finance experts tell
me that it's the timing of that payment
that is really critical and if that
money was exchanged in an effort to
impact the outcome of the election then
it could be considered a campaign
contribution or at the very least
something that the campaign should have
disclosed
now that payment that agreement is the
subject of complaints to the Federal
Election Commission and the Justice
Department John Paul Rudy Giuliani also
suggested the president could refuse a
subpoena from the special counsel is
that an option well subpoena only really
becomes an issue if the president does
not want to voluntarily cooperate with
the special counsel and in his answers
to this question Giuliani pointed to
former President Bill Clinton and the
fact that when he was subpoenaed by an
independent counsel that subpoena went
away once he came to an agreement on how
he wanted to voluntarily testify before
a grand jury so it seems that what
Giuliani is implying here is that the
president's cooperation will be on his
own terms and many people within the
president's legal circle believe the
best case scenario for the president is
to answer questions in writing with the
help of his attorneys but sources with
knowledge of the special counsels
investigation say the president's
cooperation still all being negotiated
lots of rounds of negotiation to go
Paula thanks